[Laughter]
that's great I'm happy what's going on
there citizens at the reject Nation
we're gonna watch World finite today say
John how's it going with that Chum I'm
swallowed top how are you good how are
you doing the Irish hooligan I don't
know lingo from this era but I can talk
in the voice wow look at it who didn't
hollering today in our reaction
Halloween like the moon in the night say
the whole reaction video If you can
leave a like today that'd be great comes
also subscribe hit that notification
Bell like uh like like a like a Catholic
boy ringing the bell for the pope say
available for uh our super sexy rejects
over at our patreon page oh you know
follow koi on Tick Tock I'm really
resisting doing this
15 seconds 30 seconds 30 minute video
see extra extra
that's
it easy C or Chum yeah yeah yeah and
then boys have prepper thank you for
having to set it down these highlights
[ __ ] hot in the middle of the night
Chum
one thing I didn't want to mention is
that this reaction is in color but uh on
on our patreon page just for you know
little hoops and Giggles there's gonna
be a black and white reaction highlights
cut for y'all for for the patrons if you
if you care about that anyhow let's get
to it
[Applause]
[Music]
I found out Michael gynecologist
composed the trailer now forever
Michaela
already
[Music]
awesome
this is what I have been waiting for
this is delightful since 2007.
[Music]
it's alive that may be my favorite edit
like that's fun in our modern world this
is where monsters dwell alongside those
who hunt and slaughter them with pride
none more prolific yeah there she is
this weapon isn't want of a new master
for Ulysses Bloodstone
has died
tonight
is his funeral
strangers until this night
for a ceremonial hunt which will decide
who next will wield the Bloodstone
it's like a house on a haunted hill for
hunters house on Hunter Hill
foreign
I like that use of Cutler any of these
hockette beasties your handiwork
no am I fought a few times he's never
looked so alive
I wonder if you're up to it
all these years without training without
his training
I did what I caught with you
shame I didn't turn out don't be too
easy on yourself
it was the greatest disappointment of
his life
this is a good funeral
[Laughter]
my spirits are dying
over 200 kills collectively to over 100
deaths
over a hundred yeah
so many deaf dealers in one room death
dealer
[Music]
Will Smith from Men In Black
that's the one he orchestrated his
presence in other ways
[Music]
incorrigible really
oh good
laughs
cool
I do Loop my attendance Delights you
the hunter who slays this Beast will
become our new leader taking possession
of my Bloodstone I'll be
nothing for you when I die I want that
done to my body yeah is that a new bar
forgive me
graveyard humor
[Laughter]
a man's got jokes I like how the Widow
knew like everything he was like
[Laughter]
yes every Hunter for themselves
[Music]
fascinating foreign
[Music]
off you go
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
we're gonna play marbles the squid game
model made squid games hey
[Music]
he hunts like he doesn't know what he's
doing yeah it's odd for us and they said
100 deaths not 100 kills I'm wondering
if that's a thing he hunts like a person
lost in a maze
I suggest we just
pass each other by
what I suggest we just
pass each other bye Jesus
ouch
that's how women fight that black widow
yeah
you got Moxie kid
I thought Jack would be like the main
character but it feels like Elsa is
she to me has always been a bigger
character in in the comics but I don't
know if that's just perspective
foreign
experience
yeah it feels
[Applause]
[Music]
yes nicely done
psycho
dang it's gonna say you can do more
blood too because it's black and white I
am
[Music]
the wire work is so good
[Music]
no Westworld
[Music]
my ex that man's a terrible Hunter I
know right there she did video game
hiding
wow I didn't even really notice that
yeah but no it's got such a great grip
on like the atmosphere and the sound
design yeah I'll definitely watch this
again like around Halloween lights out I
think a lot of lights and commentary is
the way to do it I'm getting a full
experience right now I don't think we
have enough lights on I wish it's just a
little underwear
oh
yeah
oh my heart man thing are you okay
well you keep saying that you're gonna
be careful each time and here we go
again you can't keep counting on me to
save you
it's the last time
oh that's a cool reveal it's weird
these little things explode so we're
gonna explode our way out of here all
you have to do is don't die
figure out where to put this and I'll
come get you I'll find you I don't know
I'm gonna talk louder
now his performance at the beginning
makes more sense
[Music]
could have spoken with more of a sense
of urgency Elsa I mean a little bit no
no no no sure
if you help me get the monster out of
here alive
I can get you the stone I'm going to
chat with him sort it out you're what
the monster's friend
no idea about my family no I don't
they follow us they stay like they
become an atmosphere I don't know
it's complicated
John likes his family
it's still an atmosphere though they
still follow you around
what are you doing when I was a kid my
dad used to tell me stories about my
crazy Aunt Francis
stuff
yeah
she was positive that she come back from
the dead at some point and she knew
that when she did she'd need
that's not bad
[Music]
an exit strategy
[Laughter]
bury me with my keys
okay stepping stone we're good
then you're on your own
and then I'll kill you on this butt I
like that they got a Latino actor for
this man that's great of course man I'll
kill you both
okay
hey
when you run into him just
treat him like an old friend
call him by his name which is Ted Ted
Teddy
Theodore I really like the pairing of
them yeah
[Music]
oh dang
[Music]
Ted
[Laughter]
your friend
is waiting for you
they did such a good job with me I think
[Music]
no
you have to shove it in there
Natasha and the Hulk yeah sing him a
lullaby
in the crack come on guy
[Music]
oh he wasn't a monster
just misunderstood oh no wow
time to Wolf out man yeah
the Bloodstone did this to you
he grabbed him
and it threw him back
it's wolf out come on
can't wait to find out what breed of
evil you are
none of you should have the stone
the hunt decides
oh I would never hurt you or hurt
anyone's name
I'm hunting that I do
is done by a part of me that is not me
and that's not the part you're with
right now
dude he is great yeah
because I lock myself in once a month
every full moon that's it
and the next full moon is in five days
we have plenty of time to figure
something out four days later
the Bloodstone is capable of
transforming you in five seconds
thanks in advance for making it quick
you could be on that wall yeah man wall
of fame
so if this is going to happen look at me
okay do not break eye contact no matter
what what are you talking about
learn her scent
and this is what I need to remember you
does it work
once
oh
please don't do this
not this way
just kill me as I am
otherwise there will be no mercy I
promise
she's doctor too
confirmed
Victoria Von Doom
time for you
to show yourself
[Music]
today but I this is a wonderfully eerie
[Music]
Tang
[Music]
oh that's great classic
[Applause]
don't look away
laughs yes
[Applause]
[Music]
stuck in here
I will Kung Fu them
I'm ready to come
these guys really do look like TV
[Music]
oh that's fantastic
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
no the black and white is getting us a
lot more fun
how's the Bloodstone
thank you
shitty night
not blade house dude the movie is so
good oh man there's a tvas just breaking
through here
[Music]
this is so much more violent than I
expected
oh what a cool device too
oh that is great no mercy
[Music]
wow
oh my God
that's great I'm happy
foreign
am I a monster
Jack call him jack not Wolfie it's a
nice name
Jack
you still in there
no
oh I think he's done such a great job on
capturing that tragedy element yeah
[Music]
you let it go oh my God you're still
alive kill your mom you will now die as
you lift a disgraced day of Father's
memory
feel the fear
awesome
[Music]
he went that way
[Laughter]
tipped over him
[Laughter]
I only wanted to make myself available
to you
brilliant and can start clearing all
this [ __ ] up
[Laughter]
oh cool yes nice one division
so where are the rainbow oh that's great
[Music]
this is color conversion they shot this
in black and white that's right yeah
because you can see the colorization
it looks cool
I went from a 30s movie to his 70s like
werewolf By Night perfect
damn look how great that looks
incredible it looks great
oh
I'm so happy
um
this is one of the best things Marvel's
done this is so good this is great
is she okay
good that's good
hey he's got a guitar
what no
no I'm the one who comes to your rescue
what are you talking about
and I cannot think of food right now
[Music]
laughs
grab that guitar play this little Coco
oh it's so special
oh you guys
that was incredible I love that so much
I was so worried when I saw the run time
for this that it was gonna be a rushed
mess that was the exact amount that I
was like this is actually really well
paced and really well executed and it's
awesome all around that was so special
let's look out for credits Easter eggs
love these credits too let's get Jake
the goat come on
put blade in here
just his voice it's like an old school
Rob Rodriguez thing to me yeah shot
chopped and scored
what a directorial debut man that was
incredible like that's up there with
Chung Chi for like top tier phase four
like that was
I love that that was beautiful yeah
this reminded me a lot of shangchi when
I think about Chef tree I think about
this tone
[Laughter]
she's great yeah I'm really impressed
because Elsa bloodstone's not an easy
character and huge respect to Harriet
Sansom Harris for holding this thing
down and like great casting all around
all around I agree
Sarah Haley Fan Man riffing on like the
20s 30s horror movies it's such a
brilliant idea that was brilliant and I
feel like he still makes it you'll
appreciate it more if you like were a
fan of those but if you if you're not
still you still I think there's still
lots and that's the run time like I felt
like that was the right run time because
it felt like those old movies like the
30s manwolf is like 48 minutes or
whatever yeah when's the Embargo in this
I want to talk about it
we didn't watch this early I mean I will
talk about it now Leonardo now
yeah I didn't catch the other woman's
name though
damn I was like he looks so much buffer
as you got to get that Marvel bot even
if you're gonna die he wasn't more than
one season of Westworld you would know
that if you watched Westworld I didn't
watch it I didn't watch it once Leonardo
since you're watching I'm really sorry
so cool that one time we got to work
together I couldn't even recall his name
I knew his name I just didn't want to
say it one guy from Westworld because I
figured you would go home not everybody
knows who Leonardo Nam is taking the
shortcut to who who he is let's see I
would have said he would have been like
oh not every Asian guy is you you racist
leader or not that was what I was ready
for so I didn't say it I was ready for
both you know it's one thing if I make
fun of you guys
and it's personal I'm sorry and I'm
gonna change the whole vibe of this room
in five seconds he'll do it next time
I'm just gonna point and shot Asian
actor Asian actor
Greg feels specifically called out for
calling us out
how to turn tables those poor boys
[Laughter]
the tables have turned
betrayal a deceit
oh yes now you know what it's like to be
a white guy you make fun of people to
make fun of you here we are I'm the
victim for being in the majority yeah
I'm right here being the cause of the
problem victimhood that was so so clever
with the social thanks of Brad Bird hey
oh cool and Anthony jacquino with uh
that was so smart was somewhere over the
rainbow doing a direct Wizard of Oz
callback that was great
all right let's chitty chatty all right
Cory where would you rank this in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe
[Laughter]
Marvel all Marvel for me this was
exceptional it was original it was
inventive it was what I've been missing
about and I and I don't disparage phase
four as much as many but like this is
what I was missing was something that
felt bold that didn't sacrifice the
Integrity of the MCU the use of this
elseworld feel like I could see man
thing jumping in in something tomorrow
but it also didn't feel like it was
sacrificing the characters you can do
both and a lot of the phase four things
when they've done something really bold
felt like it sacrificed the character
that was Elsa Bloodstone that was World
finite that was the 70s but I don't feel
like it hurt anything else in its
Journey that was such a unique piece of
art I love that so much yeah I loved it
especially with it's like I love those
Universal monster movies I think they're
fantastic and with the most important
aspect that I think modern day movies
often miss about when they try to adapt
those things is the emotional tragic
side because so much of what makes those
monsters great from the past when you're
talking about like Frankenstein is
probably the most obvious answer like
you pointed out is misunder if you watch
like Brian Frankenstein like he's just a
misunderstood guy he's not actually like
this horrifying being you know and
that's the big part of what I thought
they captured so well you know with the
werewolf werewolf finite and in the man
thing as well it's like there's this
fear of of loneliness involved with it
and I thought like oh that's so great
that that quality more than just
aesthetically pleasing of looking at
those old school horror films they
captured the mood and what you know the
external like the the external fear of
what the creature is is a manifestation
of a lot of the things internally that
these that these monsters go through and
I thought that was so present with our
two main monsters here man thing and the
Werewolf so I I thought it was
excellently done and also just
wonderfully composed in in all aspects
of sound design and didn't go too far
like the trailer really went like Full
Tilt grind house with the 30s flare to
it but this movie was sort of special
was shot it felt like a like a full
feature but this special I'm just gonna
call it a movie yeah it was it was shot
modern like with a modern day like
framing because you know if this was
like really old school it'd be a lot of
like wide Two Shots yeah it was our set
it's not as much as like cutting back
and forth and a lot of more editing and
moving shots you know like they have
that there there is but especially the
horror movies they did a lot more
editing and a lot more angles than like
just a you know a drama or an idea
there's other talkies you know but this
this was excellent I thought it really
captured the spirit and still
um what's the word not digestible
attainable for audiences palatable yeah
that works they all work all the words
work everyday yeah is good yeah you can
still I still feel like an audience can
still get on board for this even if they
didn't grow up on those movies or
weren't a big fan in fact it might click
better just because of its cool
modernness to it well yeah it Blends
really well both tones together and you
said House on Haunted Hill and I think
back to that movie often and that movie
has you know like a distinct cast of
characters a distinct group of people
you're following but so do superhero
movies and like that's a convergence
point you wouldn't necessarily think of
but then you see this and you're like oh
cool we got the perfect gallery of
eccentric hunters and what not to
populate this which feels very akin to
the now but very akin to then in its own
way maybe less outlandish back in the
day but still unique in its
characterizations and yeah this managed
to have all the charms of a comic book
and I liked the lightness of the fact
that Jack and Ted are just Buds and
they're just kind of us against the
world yeah really good natured like that
Coda at the end is really nice because
it is so sweet to temper everything else
and I loved yeah the build up then that
comes before all that and I thought
everybody who showed up as the hunters
did a great job I thought um uh uh
verusa especially Harriet Sands some
Harris was terrific kind of leading the
charge of you know the the opposition
basically your sort of antagonists that
you're up against effectively who you at
first kind of are led to believe or your
protagonists
um and yeah I thought the it managed to
have the appropriate amount of oomph in
the horror aspects and in the again
blood gags and stuff and some of the
violence that you can hide a little bit
in the black and white so that you can
have more of your cake and eat it too
um yeah
wow that was one of the most violent
things I've seen in the MCU well in that
living off a year like that yeah and the
the throat slice
the choreography on this was incredible
like I really loved the fights I loved
how they had Elsa Bloodstone moving she
she had like a really cool like low
center of gravity where she like flung
herself with her legs and like used her
body weight like there was a lot of like
Krav Maga like there was so much of like
if you're a hunter you are going to have
to use your strengths and like they
really made it so it felt like she had a
lot of history with hunting these things
that were larger than her that like she
used her body as a weapon and Elsa
Bloodstone is a really interesting
character in the comics where she's got
this like aggressive SASS and I I
literally was thinking in the last five
minutes the only thing I wish they'd had
or been able to do is swear more and
then they get like one that they got
like a [ __ ] in at the end and I was like
correct because like in the comics she's
just like all uh like when you swear in
a comic book it's all like those symbols
and letters she just swears and I was
like man that's one thing I wish we had
and then then they gave that to me uh
there's a really fun run of Deadpool
actually where uh Deadpool decides that
he's the king of the monsters like he
just takes it on himself he's like and
he's like I'm gonna run this Monster
Island for you guys and decrease himself
a monster and then Elsa Bloodstone whose
hunts monsters but is also sympathetic
towards them kind of like has a weird uh
on and off again will they won't they in
Deadpool's mind with her but in her mind
she's like this is gross and it's a
really fun like how perception is
between characters and you see how she's
characterized in the world of monsters
and there's just a lot of really fun
arrogant control without her being an
arrogant character and I thought they
nailed that really well like this felt
like Elsa Bloodstone who's that's not an
easy character to walk and then I think
the casting of gal Garcia Bernal he gave
so much heart and empathy and soul to
Arrow finite which is what the character
is you need to want to root for him and
that speech in the cage like Greg
pointed out like that that was such a
moment of oh my God I care about this
guy so much that I'm worried for him and
through her and that experience was so
20s 30s 40s monster movie through 70s
comic and then the landing thing with
man thing that I and they also set up
geniusly that man thing he and her now
with the stone could pop up in an
Avengers movie like they said that the
age thing so when they aged up the time
through that last Coda like this this
was such an a for me like it's
everything all from the comic everything
I want from a movie and it fits in the
MCU well I I think they did something
really clever to tie this to the MCU
which was the inclusion of the TVA like
TV the TVA
being part of like willing to like like
treating this ritual like it's some type
of necessity right you know what I mean
uh were because I mean you do have that
line uh from Owen Wilson in um in in uh
and Loki mentioned the vampires you
mentioned the vampires yeah yeah and the
department of nightmares I do think they
I I heard a rumor that they did try to
get Wesley announced this type of marsh
Aldi they try to get murdered
what is going on here team first
timelines yeah they did want to get
Blade in here so I I thought that was
smart because it it does tie it into the
Multiverse quality like or else worlds
as you were saying earlier but it
doesn't have to which I like yeah and it
also did the thing like I think Winter
Soldier one of the reasons I think
Winter Soldier is is right up there near
the top if not the top of my MCU depends
on the day uh is it is an Espionage
movie that happens to have Comic
characters in it this was a monster
movie that happens to have Comic
characters and if you've never read
werewolf online if you don't know who
else the Bloodstone is which is probably
most of you this will still feel like a
movie and that's so special and that's
what I feel like I've been missing from
things like the Doctor Strange's and
Thor Force like they don't feel like
their own thing nor do they feel like
the characters to me part of me was like
if Sam Remy had done multi versus
Madison black and white might have been
able to get away with that fight scene
that came out
the one where Scarlet Witch wasn't using
her magic powers
that guy's head
like oh man there's no way this would
have got in the way
yeah yeah it made sense when I got cut
but I'm like maybe if it was in black
and white might have been able to get
away with it this also reminded me of
the Neil Gaiman and Guillermo del Toro
tried to make a doctor strange movie set
in the 20s
um and that was going to be like before
Scott daryson signed on they pitched a
period piece Dr Strange that's what our
Nostalgia period is going to be now 20s
but can you imagine okay
all our soups are buying stocks but
imagine Doctor Strange In This imagine a
a you know a Ghost Rider like a any of
the midnight suns in this would be so
special I mean I mean you could probably
speak a lot to this as well is that
because you said it in the 20s or what I
mean aesthetically you said it in um
that kind of time period
20s to 40s right yeah I'm not a
historian I'm sorry so you said it in
that kind of time period you can
actually get away with a lot more of
moments that could feel campy uh if it's
like some violence or some shots that
you in color might feel student-fill me
but because it's in this aesthetic
you're like nah but it works it just
always works because of the fact that
it's it's this aesthetic so yeah yeah it
lends itself to both the dark tones and
the lighter tones which I think is nice
and in a way that doesn't rest too hard
like the promo does make you go oh this
looks like a more Grindhouse like the
movie Grindhouse style experience where
it looks like it will kind of lean on uh
yeah those Nicks and those mistakes and
it doesn't do that so much but it does
use the tone yeah to to create a sort of
natural kind of uh back and forth
between the things that are darker that
then make you go oh dang I wasn't
expecting that and then the things that
are light and fun you well I think the
trailers make you think that it might go
more aggressive horror and I could see a
version where audiences are a bit let
down by this because of the fact that it
doesn't really push that aggressive type
of just chaotic horror the way the
trailers were sort of presenting it as
it was way less chaotic than the trailer
yet no but it had that melancholic
somberness about its characters again
that is very much like those older films
and I think if you have any kind of
awareness for that you'll see like no
that this is actually the more apt way
to make this if you're going for for
that type of style overall and I I also
I mean we gotta really appreciate too
the fact that they I mean other than
like man think they they really went
practical yeah with a lot of designs
like I seen werewolf first time I was
like they did it they made him that's
what was great about putting you know
because it in color and I'm wondering
what a little trans like in color
they're probably gonna have to really
update some of the the edginess and the
shadowing right for the werewolf but in
terms of you you put them in a costume
like it just looks like a guy in a
werewolf costume and it works for this
or this version yeah it's so classic and
I like how they did kind of give him a
bit of a fighter build yeah you know I
love how it moved too I love that they
gave him like a boundingness I love like
his his like his spine seemed to
elongate where he could move like yes
they really did a lot of incredible
practical Bodywork and I was even saying
during one of the fights earlier like I
love the dichotomy when he was human how
stiff he moved like when they were
talking Elsa had this fluidity she had
this like I'm a fighter in this mode he
doesn't fight when he's not a werewolf
and I love that he looked kind of stiff
he couldn't quite navigate the world
even in addition to the fear and the way
he wasn't good at hunting which we
noticed immediately with the way he
physically moved was like someone that
didn't know how to use their body and
then she was like yeah I got this well
he had this um he had a bit of that
acrobatic martial artist approach to it
but it never went too too much didn't
become like underworld or some [ __ ] like
it it was it it still maintained being a
werewolf yeah and I thought that was
that was that was awesome there's so
much awesome that's about what the hell
David Silverman's work is the Flaming
tube I love how contained it was one two
I appreciated that they give you the
opportunity now they they did a classic
Shadow transformation you see like a
close-up on his hand but you know
werewolf movies throughout you know
their history have
a number of different motifs that I
think you're still kind of able now to
anticipate the next time we see werewolf
by night because part of me was going
okay are we gonna do the sort of uh Rick
Baker like full-on we're gonna watch it
happen transformation and not that I
ever really expect them like the next
World by night thing to do like a
full-on practical werewolf transform but
we have that to look forward to at least
what is it going to look like when we
actually watch it head on that
transformation
um but I think the reaction of Elsa
Bloodstone of course stronger no 100 I
think they did it the right way here and
I think that again the shadow
transformation is so classic and I think
yeah playing that against a reaction is
a lot more effective especially for your
first time than just seeing the
transformation up close you know yeah
and man thing's Powers were so cool like
especially in black and white to see
that that fear that power in him and he
felt so powerful like that was that was
a really cool weight to him which we
haven't seen in a lot of CGI characters
lately like I felt like in color in
black and white there was an actual man
thing like there was there was a
presence to that character which felt
like I cannot wait to see him again the
one aspect of this that I I still feel
like they could have done it in the
scripting that I did find myself kind of
craving a tad more of was the other
Hunters you could have kept the same
amount of screen time it's just the
dialogue given I I think you could have
done something to really make everyone
feel unique more unique a distinct
personality uh yeah only the Scotsman
really got the only it was only the
Scotsman he had it and then everyone he
was Scottish everyone else his
Personality yeah personality Scottish
okay cool yeah it's like if you can't
like okay give them a cool weapon or
something like that I mean they all got
like some someone of a cool Weapon It's
give them some type of personality to
really make you stand out in in some way
um other than like that's the Asian one
that's the black one that's the Scottish
one you know arm arrow and ax yeah but
no it was it was great I think for uh
and it was a solid run time yeah that
hour was perfect I think like I want now
that we've had our first special edition
I'm even more excited for the next and
the Guardians and like what we do with
our holiday specials because this is our
Halloween we got a Guardians Christmas
coming up
um that's around the corner Halloween
special then Guardians yeah we're like
six weeks out like this is moving and
grooving
um so I think it's really special that
we have the Marvel Universe this is like
what I used to defend with Marvel
putting out a lot of stuff is that this
is a special and it is unique to itself
but it all fits in the MCU and I've said
that three times in this review but I
want more things that work like this and
if that means specials instead of movies
or instead of shows yes please this was
ideal yeah 100 Hondo P anything else you
want to add on before we close out John
no I think we're good first parents of
moon night was in World by night so if
you enjoyed this uh check out some more
fun night comics and definitely check
out Elsa Bloodstone I believe there was
a
and I think it was the second episode
there was like a bus
on the top of the bus that had a uh it
had a reference to the comic number that
he had oh did you see that was that in
here no no no no oh in Moonlight I was
like I didn't even see a bus
no Moonlight yeah I think that was a
very specific Easter I was definitely
checking the names correctly I was
checking the names out on the Tombstones
and the or like in the mausoleum and the
closest one I think there was one next
to her mom or her on to whatever uh that
looked like it might have been a
reference to
um wendigo uh but I couldn't quite
discern it I love this maze to like
there's so many things I would love to
to see the breakdown or just to go back
over and pour over this forward to see
what other movies they took from yeah
because because I got not the most
dangerous game has a maze necessarily
but I got kind of that Vibe too and uh
yeah it was just like this classic
Gothic estate that has like these
sprawling grounds and yeah this this
like very specialized Garden Maze of
sorts like so many great classic tropes
some love Michael giaccino like what he
was able to do with composing and
building a world you notice you pointed
out the atmosphere uh I I want him to I
mean I don't want him to stop composing
so please just have more time in your
life but like I want more from him
because this was such a really
impressive debut and I love his use of
tone and I think his being a composer of
that repute really established he can
build a world like I could feel this
world immediately and I think that came
from the strength of him being able to
build worlds through music they did the
music too for this yeah he did the music
because yeah it's so CL like I love that
too that they really leaned into classic
strings and horns and all that stuff
I mean he probably did his best work on
this one this is going to be because he
he really had control of the narrative
yeah so we could probably hear while he
was shooting it you know what I mean
like I imagine his brain was processing
the way how like you have directors like
Edgar Wright who or Tarantino who often
make film their scenes around the the
soundtracks they want to use he probably
his brain was doing that in real time
posing yeah a while just hearing the the
score and that's so unique and that's
and it felt it that's probably how he
was able to really help
um establish an emotion too even with
such a short run time yeah I agree
because I felt every minute of this yeah
and it all felt right love those
theremin sounds all right guys are you
excited for
the werewolf and man thing to return and
when they really upped the comedy on
their adventures in the future make a
buddy cops we're really excited for the
funny thing a lot of self-aware jokes
big bad
Judd Apatow is man thing coming soon you
know they're just gonna
go ahead Marvel man thinks you got a big
man pretty excited for I love you man
thing
[Music]
they're gonna Bromance them up so much
so much
bro man things bro man things
I do want one thing I'll say is I I do
want uh because I know you really
appreciate the else of Bloodstone
fighting uh I for me was like ice in the
future for work this time around but I
would want a little bit more of a
distinct style tour fighting style
not really I mean
this is usually how they choreograph
women in fight scene but there wasn't on
any like they actually let her fight so
like that was that was what I liked it
was like a bunch of like freaking like
when she does the takes them down like I
like how the flips were in like one shot
and it was good choreography and when
she does like wrap her legs around yeah
it all felt like more like yeah you
could actually keep it in camera versus
like a cut uh which I like uh I I still
so I think the way captured wise was
different choreography wise I I want
something that really has a distinct
style of it's like they found a distinct
style for the werewolf which is easier
to lean into because you got an actual
monster but for her you know it's also
Bloodstone you fight your character I
want I would like them to
see what different thing they can do the
way they found it for cap and Winter
Soldier like yeah yeah they didn't find
it for him in the first one but in
Winter Soldier they're like we gotta
find style for Captain America yeah and
I think they could do that for Elsa
Bloodstone shout out to ninja brewski
the stunt guy for Captain America who is
also Daredevil stunt double for the
hallway fight great guy oh Chris
Brewster buddy
all right guys we'll leave your thoughts
down below subscribe click that Bell
follow koi on the koi John Dro show on
tick tock
flaming tubas
thank you guys
[Music]